[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL OLSHANSKY: Hi.
My name is Daniel Olshansky.
I'm Chet's intern here on the
Android Team at Google.
And today, I'll be discussing
a few card flip innovations.
So today, I'll just show you how
to flip cards, both from
side to side, out and in, as
well as a few little tricks on
how to do graphic animations on
darkening and spinning the
cards when you need to.
The main trick to today's
animation is going to be the
fact that, after every single
animation, we're going to
update the Layer parameters such
that future animations
are not going to be dependent
on the values of previous
animations.
So we'll be animating
the properties.
But then, at the end of every
single animation, we'll be
setting them all back to zero,
such that any future
animations won't be dependent on
what has been done before.
So going straight into the
demo, here, we have a
stack of red cards.
I can use touch events to flip
it from right to left.
Similarly, they can flip
it from left to right.
The speed at which this animates
is actually dependent
on the speed at which
you fling it.
You can also swipe down to open
a stack of cards or swipe
back up to close a stack of
cards, place both stacks.
Or if you tap on a stack, then
there's a little delayed
animation showing you how to
rotate a full stack of cards
completely.
So jumping straight into the
code, there is a lot of
boilerplate code that you can
look into where you handle all
the touches, determine which
way I'm flinging
and things like that.
But the interesting things
happen here in Card View.
So scrolling down, initially,
one of the things you need to
note is that Views, and in turn
Image Views, have this
property called Set
Camera Distance.
So what this actually lets you
do is set the position along
the Zed-axis of how
far you want to be
from the actual animation.
Originally, in this animation,
if you were to set it back to
its default value, you would see
that we don't actually see
the flip animation, because it
happens behind the screen.
After that, we retrieved the
bitmaps that we used for the
front and the back
of the cards.
And keep going down.
Here, this is important
to note.
What we're doing to the bitmap
drawable is adding a one-pixel
transparent border.
And the reason we're doing this
is, when you're rotating
a rectangle within some view,
the edges don't actually have
any values that they can
retrieve outside the
boundaries of the rectangle.
So you end up getting these
very jagged edges when you
rotate a rectangle.
But this problem can be very
easily [? abided ?], simply by
having a one-pixel transparent
border.
And it's done right here.
And then you will see that the
edges are actually smooth as
you rotate the cards.
Then there's two methods, flip
from left to right, and flip
from right to left.
Before we actually call the
flipping animation, we need to
set the pivot.
By default, the x and y pivots
of all views are along center.
So if you were to rotate
it, it would only
rotate about its center.
But setting these manually would
give us more precision
as to how we want
to animate it.
Then there's a method called
flip horizontally, after we
set the pivot.
What this does is set up a lot
of use property values hold,
or object animators, and things
like that to actually
animate the rotation
of it along the
y-axis by 180 degrees.
We also added translation
animation such that, when it
finishes animating, it's in the
correct offset within the
corresponding pile that
it animated to.
And what we're also doing is
adding an update listener such
that, as it's animating, we
need to make sure when it
reached the halfway point.
And at the halfway point, we
want to switch the drawable
from the red bitmap to the blue
bitmap, or the other way
around, because it's on
the other side now.
Going down farther more, I'm
setting up a few key frame
animations on a property
called Shadow.
This is a custom property used
to darken the image as it's
animating, which I'll show
you in a second.
Scrolling down even more, I
set a duration using the
velocity passed in from the
fling, and then use an
animator set to play all
of these together.
At the end of the animation, I
need to update the bitmaps and
set some default values back
to their default values.
So like I said, I'm
animating a custom
property called Shadow.
So since my string is Shadow, my
Object Animator is going to
look for a property on that
target called Set
Shadow right here.
And all I'm doing here is using
alpha blending imported
off mode multiply.
And all this does is
just darken the
image, as it's animating.
And that's how you get that
shadow-like effect.
Toggle front shown, simply
switches the
red and blue bitmaps.
That switches the flag
determining which bitmap
you're using.
And there's some more very
simple boilerplate code to do
some set up things
here as well.
So the thing is a non-draw.
When I'm flipping my card,
instead of actually creating a
new bitmap that's horizontally
mirrored from my original
bitmap, all I'm really doing
is concatenating my canvas
with a matrix that does
that exact same thing.
So this way, it's a lot
more efficient.
It doesn't use as much memory.
It uses the exact same bitmap.
But I'm still able to achieve
that horizontal mirroring
effect of the image after I've
actually flipped it.
And the reason I need to do
that is because in Update
Layer Parameters, I set the
rotation x and y back to zero.
That's what I'm trying
to do here.
I'm trying to make any future
animations be independent of
what they were before.
But in order to achieve that, I
also need to update the left
margin of my Layer parameters
to be exactly where it is
after the animation, and then,
of course, update the
parameters as well.
So this, in conjunction with
customizing the canvas when I
need to lets me achieve this
whole independence effect
after every single animation.
Again, some simple code to
offset it where I need to,
switch the bitmaps.
So here's the code for rotating
the actual card.
What this does is determine what
angle I should rotate it
by, depending on how far the
card is down the stack.
And then I simply return Object
Animator that rotates
that view by that angle.
The other thing that I can also
do is when I tap on a
card and all the cards flip in
a circle with a certain delay
between them, it's almost the
same animation, except the
angle is always 360 degrees.
But the other thing to note is
that you need a start delay.
The cards on the tops are
animating almost immediately,
whereas, the cards underneath
only start animating when all
the cards above that card have
already gone past a certain
point in the animation.
So I add a different start
delay, depending
on where card is.
And then I play all those
animations together.
So that's how you actually get
the animations for every
individual card.
And if you look in the card
[INAUDIBLE] activity, which is
the main activity, all I'm doing
here is looping through
all my cards when some stack
has been tapped.
I'd retrieve that Object
Animator that I can get from
my Card View.
And the other thing I'm
doing is bringing that
child to the front.
So depending on how they're
flipping the cards, I don't
exactly know whether all the
cards on the right stack are
on top of the cards
on the left stack.
So I'm just sequentially calling
bring child to front,
to change the set order of all
the cards in the stack that
I'm animating.
And the other thing you need to
do is always call request
layout after you've called bring
child to front, in order
for that change to
take effect.
Otherwise, you'll have to wait
for the child to be brought to
front until somebody
has requested a
layout on your view.
Very similarly, in order to
achieve the full card
rotation, I am retrieving the
Object Animators from all the
cards, bringing the objects to
the front, and doing almost
the exact same thing, except
with a different Object
Animator, which I can retrieve
from my Card View.
So that's pretty much how you
can flip cards, rotate them,
and animate them in
different ways.
Thanks.